octo passe traveler et pour moi de très
loin le meilleur jeux 2018
il est une surprise que l'on n'attendait
pas spécialement et qui pourtant ne
peine pas à se hisser au rang de
chefs-d'oeuvre parmi les plus grands
jeux vidéo de notre histoire vous allez
trouver que j'y vais certainement un
petit peu fort mais c'est simplement mon
avis et j'espère pouvoir vous concocter
d'autres vidéos riche sur ce jeu je ne
vous dis pas tout ça pour rien square
enix est une firme qui me passionne
depuis maintenant vingt deux années je
pense vous bassiner assez comme ça avec
la saga final fantasy et octo passe n'y
fera pas exception et me passionne tout
autant voire encore plus cependant nous
ne sommes pas là pour ça si j'estime que
vous êtes réceptif des vidéos sur
octobre passe ce sera avec plaisir que
je vous parlerai de tous les sucres et
du jeu ou autre détail que j'essaye de
défilé de jour en jour
et justement il est temps d'amener une
théorie qui révèle encore plus de choses
que n'a révélé l'histoire avant toute
chose j'aimerais vous prévenir que la
théorie dont nous allons parler traite
des parties du scénario les plus
poussées du jeu soit la fin de
l'histoire de notre chère octuor alias
le poste game la fin ultime du voyage ou
tout simplement la fin de leurs
chapitres respectifs
je vous laisse donc cinq petites
secondes pour quitter la vidéo ou cliqué
sur le time code proposé afin d'éviter
et tout spoil de l'histoire
[Musique]
tout d'abord laissez-moi vous raconter
l'histoire de g cros ford g cros ford
est un apothicaire plus connu dans
l'histoire dr passe comme l'idole dalfin
qui le sauva d'une terrible maladie
devant l'emporter mais si nous nous
tournons encore plus vers le lors du
personnage secondaire nous savons que g
est issu d'une très ancienne lignée de
sorciers descendants dos d'un cros ford
un sorcier qui ferma la porte de
finissent à l'est des pires draconique
et qui est des abbey golf un prince
therrien a fondé la célèbre cité de korn
bourg pour en revenir à l'histoire
principale du grand apothicaires g cros
ford entrepris un long voyage pour créer
un élixir capable de guérir sa femme
d'une très grave maladie détruisant le
corps avec la présence de marc violacé
sur ce dernier
malheureusement c'est au bout de son
épopée lors de son retour après avoir
obtenu tous les ingrédients nécessaires
à l'élixir qu'il se rendit compte qu'il
était déjà trop tard sa femme son épouse
l'avait quittée emporté par la maladie
et ce à tout jamais c'est lors des
funérailles de sa moitié qui fit la
rencontre d'une étrange femme du nom de
li blacks
oulaï blacks comme vous préférez cette
dernière le charme à avec l'espoir de
pouvoir revoir sa femme et une dernière
fois pris par les sentiments et ne
pouvant ignorer cette proposition
g entrepris son ultime voyage jusqu'à la
cité en ruine de korn bourg son périple
l'amena à passer par ruisseau clair où
il fait la rencontre d'un jeune garçon à
l'article de la mort
c'était al fine greengrass g reconnu les
symptômes du jeune homme sans hésiter à
l' fines étaient atteints de la même
maladie que sa femme rames étaient
toujours en possession de l'élixir sur
lui ils avaient l'espoir de pouvoir
ramener sa femme du fin fond du portail
de finisse grâce à ce dernier réalisant
que cet espoir été peine perdue tout
comme le futur de sa propre histoire à g
utilisa son élixir sur al fine et lui
laisse à tout son attirail d'apothicaire
parce qu'il rêvait de devenir comme lui
un jour ou l'autre c'est au portail de
fini ce que les choses se compliquent
leigh blake n'avait pas du tout prévu de
ramener la femme de l'apothicaire mais
prévoyait de se servir de lui pour
amener galles des rats le dieu du mal
enfermé au fin fond de l'enfer par les
douze dieux principaux de ce monde
g compris l'acte de leigh blake il avait
connaissance qu'il est est issu d'une
grande lignée de sorciers et que l'un de
ses ascendants avait fermé de sa main la
porte de finissent ils n'avaient pas été
choisis par hasard par leigh blake g
cross ford les salit black effectué son
rituel afin de pouvoir le contrecarrer
au moment propice car il savait que
cette dernière si elle échoue et avec
lui et bien se tournerait vers son fils
quitte l'apothicaire se vit se
transformer en quelque chose d'inhumain
avec une puissance incommensurable
permettant d' affaiblir leigh blake et
d'interrompre le rituel il en profita
alors pour s'échapper mais
malheureusement la transformation avait
déjà opéré bien je pense avoir apporté
assez d'éléments pour laisser la place à
cyrus
seul un érudit de son calibre peut nous
permettre de trouver les réponses quant
à la suite de cette histoire ses
tatouages cyrus
shalit guen
[Musique]
oh
partent au causse
ah non
partent aux côtes
[Musique]
oh
which means that
[Musique]
merci cyrus
à négliger dans la recherche de vérité
effectivement tout porte à croire que g
cros ford soit devenue aux yeux rouges
amenons les arguments prouvant la
véracité de la théorie en premier lieu
comme affirmé récemment toutes les
histoires propres à nos protagonistes
principaux finissent par se rejoignent
et à partir du chapitre iv avec pour
sujet commun la porte de finisse ou g
cros ford avant le post game il était
difficile de remarquer cette liaison par
rapport à l'histoire dalfin qui est lié
par son périple à g puis les tresses
acquis au final était en possession du
journal du célèbre apothicaires qui fut
recueilli par léon bast râle comme
monnaie d échange d'un voyage en mer
pour rentrer chez lui
nous pouvons d'ailleurs supposer qu'à
smeralda et son maître ou amis ne sait
pas trop qui sait était à la recherche
du journal le trait ça pour
potentiellement avoir des informations
données par gramme permettant de révéler
des choses sur la porte de finisse mais
il n'en était rien d'où la réaction
d'esmeralda par rapport à ce qu'elle
découvrit dans le livre seulement
l'histoire d'annie ce n'était en aucun
cas en rapport avec le grand
apothicaires ou la porte de finissent à
part peut-être et rouge comme une
créature provenant des enfers est
logique du jeu n'aurait pas permis un
personnage soit mise à l'écart pour le
poste game pourquoi les histoires des
autres protagonistes seraient plus
importante que celle d'anne it
les développeurs ont bien évidemment
tout prévu j'ai d'abord ressenti un goût
amer par rapport à la fin de l'histoire
d'annie tu la première fois que je les
fait je ne réussissais pas à trouver le
rapport avec la fin des autres et
pourtant aux yeux rouges est définie par
m santa comme la créature la plus
effroyable qu'il n'ait jamais pu
affronter une créature échappant à tous
ces pièges grâce à une possible
intelligence humaine
du moins c'est ce qu'il mentionne
ensuite à annie affirme que cette
créature n'a rien de naturel qu'elle
n'arrive pas à lire en elle en son coeur
alors qu'elle y arrive pour chaque
créature de ce monde
eh bien pourquoi ça à annie tu es loin
d'être experte dans les relations
humaines et elle l'a prouvé à de maintes
reprises annie ne sait pas lire dans le
coeur des hommes
elle ne connaît rien de bien concret
dans les humains preuve une fois de plus
que ce n'est pas une créature comme les
autres et qu'elle serait à la base
humaine à la fin du combat annick le
prouve encore plus avec le terne 2 quel
est ce maléfice
de plus si nous continuons dans les
détails la créature est nommé oeil rouge
zonta affirme même que l' on le surnomme
comme ça car on ne sait pas s'il a un
nom ou s'il en avait un
square enix laisse énormément de détails
dans ces jeux afin que l'on puisse
deviner certaines choses nous en avons
l'exemple avec orone quand il parle de
jake dans l'effectif ces éléments ne
sont repéra que si vous jouez une
deuxième fois au jeu et ils ne sont
justement pas là par hasard
enfin bref pourquoi ils l'ont surnommé
oeil rouge de part la couleur de ses
yeux évidemment c'est une créature
humanoïde aux yeux rouges
si nous la comparons à tous les autres
protagonistes du jeu seul lit black
possède également les yeux rouges elle
rouge est donc une créature issue des
enfers ce détail affirmerait le lieu
commun de leurs créations à lui et les
blacks je ne pense pas avoir besoin de
préciser pourquoi rouge est humanoïdes
en possédant deux soi-disant bras et
jambes détails très troublant reste le
pré combat contre la bête
écoutez bien le hurlement deuil rouge
[Musique]
ceci m'a énormément troubler la première
fois que je les combattu pourquoi ce cri
mi-bête minimes 1 on distingue très
fortement la voix d'un homme dans le
hurlement cependant cette voie n'est pas
présente dans la version japonaise du
jeu
allez savoir pourquoi peut-être que la
version européenne voulait rendre le
mystère plus explicite
on ne saura probablement pas si nous
nous référons à l'histoire de g proposé
par le post game on ressent cette
complexité entre l'homme et la créature
que g c'est qu'il était un homme mais
que la créature prend le dessus à de
nombreux moments
d'où certainement ce cri démoniaque mixé
entre la bête et la voix de g
enfin histoire de conclure la théorie g
a disparu il y a environ 10 ans par
rapport au présent du jeu santas émis
quant à lui à chasser la bête un an
avant que and it ne se mette à faire la
chasse elle même cela veut dire que g et
le temps de se changer pendant neuf
longues années aux abords de cornes
bourg donc quitte a eu le temps de
grandir et devenir un adulte puisque son
père a disparu quand il n'était encore
qu'un enfant pour continuer zone temps
affirment qu'ils ont réussi à faire fuir
la bête de son territoire et qui s'est
réfugié à guédé rock qui d'ailleurs si
on regarde la map n'est pas si loin que
ça de korneuburg si nous retournons voir
les écrits de graham présent dans les
enfers donc certainement durant sa
transformation ou une fois que vous avez
vaincu à et rouge peut-être vous pouvez
distinguer qu'il souffre du fait de ne
pas être reconnu comme un homme et donc
d'être chassé certainement pas renta ou
d'autres hommes auparavant si je vous
parle en dernier de ces petits détails
c'est pour justement vous
prouver la cohérence qu'il ya entre
l'histoire de hull rouge et de graham
cross ford et qui évidemment les
développeurs avaient tout prévu depuis
le début ce jeu est très bien pensée est
une réelle merveille enfin voila je
pense qu'avec toutes ces informations
nous pouvons affirmer et clamer haut et
fort que oeil rouge est bel et bien g
cros ford legrand apothicaires certains
spéculent que g ce sera incarnée en le
dragon que combattu à hannut lors de son
périple puisque graham est avant tout
issu d'une lignée de sorciers liés aux
dragons et au pire draconique c'est
pourquoi on affronte la forme dhombres
du dragon dans les enfers et que c'est
lui qui nous transmet une part de récits
de g
mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec ceux
ci g a été victime du rituel dhombres de
l'ibla qui le change en une créature
je ne pense pas qu'un dragon soit
vraiment une créature horrifique des
enfers contrairement à eux rouge
surtout que l'origine de la bête
provient du portail de finissent la fin
du combat ultime nous prouve justement
que g est enfin libéré de cette forme
démoniaque qui était heureux rouge et
peut enfin se reposer
il ne pouvait pas être l'ombre du dragon
tués et le fantôme de lui même je sais
pas si vous me suivez
enfin bref octo passe est un jeu
réellement incroyable et je suis
tellement heureux d'avoir pu lui rendre
hommage et de vous en parler
j'espère que cette vidéo n'est pas la
fin du voyage et que mes idées de
prochaines vidéos sur l'univers d'octo
passe ne finiront pas au fin fond de
l'enfer oui alors n'hésitez pas à
soutenir en me disant si vous aimeriez
d'autres vidéos sur octobasse traveller
j'en serais personnellement ravi a
laissé un gros pouce bleus si la vidéo
vous a plu à vous abonner ou partager la
vidéo si vous le désirez j'ai également
à twitter où vous pouvez me suivre
mais dès financièrement sur ce type en
regardant quelques pubs c'était argot
rock et que le lie à lord soit avec toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]